erst und zweitstimme was wählen wir da
überhaupt bei der bundestagswahl hat man
zwei stimmen mit der erststimme wählt
man die person aus dem eigenen wahlkreis
also die so genannte direktkandidat in
beziehungsweise den direktkandidaten wer
die meisten stimmen bekommt der ist
direkt in den bundestag gewählt und weil
in jedem wahlkreis eine person bestimmt
wird ist somit im grunde auch jede
region vertreten mit der zweitstimme
wählt man eine partei und diese stimme
ist dann ausschlaggebend wie viele sitze
die partei im bundestag bekommt welche
person für die partei in den bundestag
gehen das wird über so genannte
landeslisten geregelt und die hat jede
partei vorher festgelegt in so einer
reihenfolge und die die ganz oben stehen
die haben die besten chancen und je mehr
zweitstimmen einer partei bekommt desto
besser ist das für diejenigen die auf
der landesliste etwas weiter unten
stehen weil das erhöht die chancen damit
sie auch ins parlament kommen